this is the best time of year for
serious movie buffs the hollywood awards
season over the next few weeks the
studio's will deliver a wide range of
films mostly dramas aimed at oscar
voters and other movie and media
professionals so let's get a look at
some of them here to tell us about this
year's field is Fandango managing editor
Eric Davis aired good morning good
morning this actually looks like a
pretty exciting crop of films coming up
here yeah it's a good year it's opposite
of last year no hashtag oscarssowhite
this year we have multiple films with
diverse ensemble yeah highlight people
of color I think every movie we're going
to talk about today should be nominated
for Best Picture many of them if not all
of them will be okay so let's start at
the top of the list first up is silence
martin scorsese's Scorsese am I saying
that correctly yes passion project so
he's wanted to make for 30 years it's
definitely a passion project that
follows to 17th century Jesuit priests
played by andrew garfield and adam
driver who we see here who are traveling
through Japan spreading Christianity
looking for their missing mentor not the
sexiest of plot descriptions but this is
a film he's wanted to make for decades
that means we're going to get the best
of Martin Scorsese as a filmmaker if we
get the best of him as a filmmaker it's
one of the best films of the year no
doubt trailer very intense the trailer
and two great actors yes we're having a
moment exactly all right next up fences
which comes from the Pulitzer
prize-winning play directed and starring
Denzel Washington yes who played this
character on the stage as well this is
african-american family late 1950s the
evolving relationships between a father
and a son husband and a wife you know
Denzel Washington and Viola Davis are so
good in this film we're not just talking
about two of the best performances a
year I think these are two of the best
performances of the last 20 years Wow
yes I think they both want tony awards
for playing these characters on the
stage they're both going to win Oscars
for playing these characters on the big
screen lock it in haha Wow take it to
the races hi Eric also on this list is
one of my favorite movies of the year
moonlight by Barry Jenkins and
incredibly moving but a smaller film
smaller film what we always see these
kind of low-budget underdogs sneak their
way into the awards conversation this
year it's moonlight a very touching
poignant three-part story a come
of age of about african-american boy
who's sort of grappling with his
sexuality amidst a world of drug dealers
and gangbangers and we've seen movies
that are set in this world before but
nothing quite felt as a point of view
each part feels like its own experience
it is so full in his melancholy it is
masterfully directed by this man named
Barry Jenkins who I think is going to go
on to some great things after this movie
NAB's a ton of nominations already got
six independence Independent Spirit
Award nominations the other day so it's
on its way our next contender
manchester-by-the-sea Casey Affleck
Michelle Williams yeah move over Ben
Affleck make some room for the other
athletic brother Casey Affleck is
tremendous in this film about a man who
returns to his hometown to kind of make
take care of the affairs of his brother
after he passes away suddenly take care
of his nephew played by Lucas hedges who
we see he may go on to be nominated as
well Lucas hedges really good in this
film there's a gut punch of a movie it's
going to hurt a little bit bring the
tissues but you know what it is it is so
real it feels like you're peeking in and
spying on this family credible
performances all around i think it's
going to be a big-time nomination I'm
sure we're going to hear that Affleck
Massachusetts end oh yes okay hidden
figures is the true untold story of
three african-american women who are
mathematicians that's weren't a 60
working for NASA this is a meat potatoes
of the space race when America is trying
to beat Russia into space beat them to
the moon and these women were integral
parts of that and this is during
segregation so they have tons of
obstacles to deal with Octavia Spencer a
janelle monáe murray and taraji p henson
my love taraji p he's great you know
this is I think one of the best crowd
pleasers of the year and never
underestimate a crowd pleaser because
those are usually the movies that win
best picture and I think this is one of
the best ones in our lands as well all
right you brought that up I'm listening
by this film because we an old-school
Hollywood musical yes old school but
also new school this is a movie musical
from director Damien Chazelle who did
whiplash a couple of years back and it
is just tremendous is my favorite movie
of the year ryan s comes out comes out
play aspiring artists who fall in love
he is a jazz pianist she is an actress
what happens when one of you becomes
more successful than the other this is
just a beautiful love letter to Los
Angeles to any kind of art that's
produced on a stage be it a jazz set of
musical a movie just one of the most
delightfully compelling experiences you
will have at a movie theater this Wow
please okay amazing chemistry with this
you okay lion and Jackie tell us about
those two lion fascinating real-life
story about a little boy from India who
gets lost when he's going look for work
with his brother gets lost for years
eventually he's adopted by an Australian
couple and then as an adult he uses
google earth to try to find his family
again I met the the real-life guy this
guy named suru he's a great guy
compelling film powerful ending and
Jackie Natalie portant is just
phenomenal you're not bending it there
gently for Natalie Portman's Tanaka the
whole stop now stop it's all about
Natalie Portman I think she's a
frontrunner for best actress has two
former first lady Jackie Kennedy and you
know it in this film she shows that
Jackie Kennedy hours and days mediate
hours and days after President Kennedy's
assassination a Jackie Kennedy who's
standing tall despite everything her
entire life crumbling around her adhere
she is taking ownership over her
family's legacy I think Portland is
extraordinary in this film good film not
a great film great Mormont's from
Natalie poor caveat Eric I'm going to be
sitting in the dark pounding popcorn
after the rest of the year thank you for
giving me a long list eric has a long
list